okay so I'm gonna go back to the
slightly starvin unfortunately I'm not
giving a chalked up but I'll make it
slow enough that looks like a chopped-up
okay
so we start with two random variables X
and x hat and then you can always write
mutual information in this form and
local differential privacy in this form
and something I'm hoping you may be able
to get from this talk is maybe a bunch
of measures that go from here and then
there's maximal linkage and then there's
LDP and maybe epsilon after maybe R any
I don't know oh that's I hope so I'm
gonna go back to maximal leakage or a
minute I think you know it so I'm just
gonna put it in here most of my slides
will go in this fashion step by step so
so we're so inspired by Aaron's work
that despite all our agreement to use
the same notation my student used his
original notation which was you instead
of s and it was just too late to go back
and change it so we'll stick with uu is
your secret variable any function of X
so this question mark sort of means any
function of X ok and I want to iterate
this because you will sometimes see just
an arrow and that means a specific
function of X I'll make that clear in
bit so you know this right it's a it's a
ratio and and then there's the supremum
over all possible functions of X that
that you captures okay I want to sort of
hint this I feel this is an adversary
for me this definition is from an
adversarial viewpoint the adversary
gained something from having this
release and the adversary is assumed to
be a reasonably strong adversary because
it has this prior knowledge
maybe I Adam Aaron doesn't agree with me
perhaps I okay one of the things I hope
comes out of this is some relationship
between these things okay so this part
of the talk is really truly the work of
my awesome graduate student and my
amazing colleague Oliver and my another
amazing collaborator flock all right so
here's a problem setup right X is some
X's are unavailable could also be a data
set X hat is some output from this
unavailable through this mapping
randomized mechanism right you could be
any function of X and then I look at an
adversary that wishes to estimate you as
you had from exit ok that's what all of
this is alright what I'm actually going
to do is take all these measures and
look at it from a loss function
viewpoint alright so I just already said
this this is my pictorial notation if
you see a question mark with that arrow
it means any you alright and if you for
example this need not just be blue red
it could have been any thing if you see
just a pure arrow because I will
introduce a very specific measure for
that which then generalizes this then
it's a very specific you I call it
context aware for example it could be
just race right and the other data set
okay all right so what I'm gonna do
first is take a loss function
perspective so everybody knows mutual
information here right there's X there's
X hat there's some you that I'm
interested in that's related to X I'm
going to estimate it as you have okay so
I have this Markov chain okay so here's
a loss function I'm gonna look at log
loss right so the adversary is using
this loss function this is what it wants
to minimize right so it makes an
estimate of you as you had right after
you had a sum you given X hat and it
takes the log of the negative log of
that right so immediately what the
adversary strategy is is the one that
minimizes this loss function okay so
here's a definition of what the
adversary gains it's the obviously this
is going to be smaller than without
having this X hat so it's the gain or
the decrease in the loss the regret as a
result of having X hat so you work it
out you get the
information between you and exit okay
all right so from the data processing
inequality I take a supermom over all
possible such hues
I get mutual information so in some
sense if I'm minimizing mutual
information I'm using and I'm using a so
I'm actually doing some kind of learning
algorithm where I use log losses need a
great function okay and the learning
algorithm is perhaps even learning the
distribution empirical oh all right so
so basically what this means is that the
this is an advocacy that's refining its
belief and it's inference gain is really
just matching for me okay all right so
now I'm gonna give you a loss function
per spectrum of maximally okay so now if
you take the loss function as the
probability of guessing error right so
this is the probability of correctly
guessing one minus this is the
probability of error then if I minimize
this on average right so the the
automatically strategy is to pick the
one that minimizes saying you know what
that is that's the best guess right the
loss function that becomes a 0 1 loss
function in other words what I started
with was the sigmoid loss function and
in the limit of the best adversarial
strategy which is picking the U that's
the most likely to occur given this X
hat if you put back this strategy in
there this loss function actually
basically just gives me the 0 1 loss
function it gives it has a weight of 0
for the right correct guess and a way to
one for all other guesses
that's what why didn't you start with
zero one muscle when I start with the
zero soft loss no because actually the
loss functions are all soft cast soft
soft losses and it's only in the limit I
mean even in the universe of loss
functions I mean this is just the
sigmoid loss function it's only when you
put the right strategy in place do you
get zero one
okay
so then another way of writing maximum
leakage is basically the gain for the
adversary so this is this is what its
loss would have been so it's a slightly
different way of writing it here I take
the I mean it's a log of a ratio of two
things right exactly this where the
adversary was first minimizing this
exact loss function but without any
knowledge and then minimizing it with
this okay what I did here was the loss
function is 1 minus the probability of
correctly guessing so you maximize when
you just take the reward function which
is the probability of correctly guess
so the underlying loss function for
maximum leakage is really just the
probability of correctly guessing okay
so I'm sorry
the ever site here is picking both U and
P you have given access it's a
realization and a distribution know the
adversary so defining a belief but the
belief the way it's gonna refine this
belief is using this loss function U is
the actual secret thing it only picks
the ever so just fix P you have given X
that's right that's the adversary
strategy but in in this in this for this
particular function the adversary's
strategy boils down to actually a point
you suffered a belief it's one one final
answer it's a hard decision instead of a
soft decision like it was for mutual
information
yeah okay any other questions yeah so I
should have put that soup remember now I
want to put the supremum unit
all right so the way I look at maximal
linkages it quantifies the maximum and
pain of inference gain that a guessing
adversary I think that's what Aaron
called it right okay so here's a sort of
a visualization of what we just did if
the adversary wanted to estimate
something that's a binomial random
variable what it would do if reduce it
uses log loss as it's done and often
learning applications is get this soft
decision at the end we make a hard
decision after that but if you use
Maxwell leakage if you zero one loss if
you could then you would get this exact
point if you a sigmoid loss it boiled
down to the zero one loss and you get
one you make one decision the x-axis is
just the values of you because you you
know us twenty possibilities is at
twenty it's a binomial right so it's 20
coin flips there's up to 20 heads or
zero heads right so if the best the
adversary could could do was actually
learn the original prior itself this is
what the distribution would look like as
all I'm saying
Mysterio would look like some seniors
are trying to guess a secret which is a
discrete number between 0 and 20 if you
happen to have access to the prior on
that secret what okay I see now I think
I got so
you probably set this like four
different ways okay so you're managing
the adversary's output here rather than
just a specific guess is actually a
distribution yes you want to maximize
some score of that distribution and if
the score you're maximizing is like the
probability of agreement then you should
just that distribution should be a point
distribution if you're trying to
minimize some expected sort of KL style
thing then you get mutual information
and and then it's a soft position
correct everybody's as violently an
agreement with me as Adam is okay so
what I'm going to do is interpolate
between these two and introduce a loss
function first I call it alpha loss
right so it's not very hard to do this
alpha is going to take a value from one
to infinity okay and here's what I do
I'm still looking at a soft position
probability but I raise it to this power
one minus one over alpha and then I'm
gonna scale it by alpha over alpha minus
the scaling is just to get all the rainy
stuff to go through later right okay
so if you take this loss function you
apply the limit as alpha goes to one
loss and it's continuous extension at
alpha as alpha equals infinity you get
the sigmoid loss
so here's a plot of how that looks like
you know the same so this is just as a
function of the probability you know
from 0 to 1 so blog loss is actually
going to go off right it's it's it's
nice and convex but it also has a
singularity at 0 and these other things
and in the limit you can see the sigmoid
losses coming as a straight line so I'm
gonna build a whole class of measures
based on this loss function it's not
very hard to see now and to do that so
keep in mind this is sort of the
probability of correctly guessing some
exponent you know some some power of the
probability right so I minimize this is
equivalent to maximizing just that
probability as you go along okay so my
information leakage is the scaled rock
logarithmic increase in expected reward
so it's very similar to maximum leakage
in that sense right so but I'm going to
choose two measures one where I say I
know you and I'm only worried about like
particular you and other or s and other
where I look at all possible random
functions s the data X okay so I know
all of you know this but just bear with
me because I think when you see those
measures later it might help you
everybody knows Shannon entropy and
everybody also knows Raney entropy and
Shannon is a special case of ready for
alpha equals 1 and ready the way the
measure is is it's actually like the
Alpha norm of the probability that's
used to give you some measure of
information right ok then everybody
knows KO distance and Kail this is a
special case of the rainier divergence
for alpha equals 1 and so there are any
divergence is sort of written like this
but this this is what it is and here
it's really the expectation over this
probability in the denominator
the reason I'm doing this is just
because these measures come up so maybe
some visualization might help
so mutual information can be written in
a whole bunch of different ways and
through through the KL divergence and
also as a minimum of the KL divergence
for this hour and this output happens to
be the marginal of the Joint
Distribution of X okay that is the one
that gives you so as Erin said earlier
when it comes to generalizing Raney
entropy to get come up with some some
other versions of visual information
there are many possibilities so a
remoter was one who came up with this
possibility he said why don't I just do
it just the way Shannon did it it's the
difference of the Aeromotive entropy for
some X - it's the the Renia entropy for
some X - the conditional Raney entropy
of X given some release say Y and this
is already called there's a a up here
because it's in honor of coromoto who
came up with this conditional rennie
entropy measure okay so the right way
just vaguely visualized this is as
follows
this is a posterior if you think about
going from X to Y by the way this
doesn't have the same beautiful Shannon
like properties of it's not symmetric
okay so we go from X to Y and so you're
looking at for every output the
conditional of X you take its norm and
you take that weight weighted sum of
that okay so this is a measure of
information let's call the area motor
Mutual for me so you can subtract this
Anderson you get the area moto-meter
right so another generalization is the
sips in that sort of came out of Aaron's
talk and spoke about sips in for alpha
equals infinity but you can look at sips
in for all alpha from 1 to infinity
alpha equals 1 you get back mutual
information
simpson is defined very differently
substance at the Rainier divergence of a
Joint Distribution of X and y and then
and its distance to this product of the
marginals and the Y that actually
minimizes this is not just the marginal
of P X Y for y it is a tilted marginal
so a visualization of that is slightly
different now you actually look at the
inner product for for any output of the
conditional and the the input the X
itself okay
so just I try to be German I mean
Simpson came at it from this notion of
information radius you give me a whole
bunch of conditional distributions it's
some weights how do I come up with a
centroid for it and that was substance
focus the only reason I bring up these
things is these measures come up when we
look it up
the best like in the in the Shannon
context the best sort of distribution on
why is really the unmodified marginal do
we it's the marginal of the joint
distribution pxy here the marginal is a
is a tilted to be a little bit careful
it's the yeah so the marginal on Y would
be the the probability of Y raised to
offer divided by its some of that so
it's a it was what's called a tilted
distribution
that's what should be and then when you
plug it back and you would get this
okay
so this alpha is sort of like a two
thing you so visually actually okay I'll
get to the it comes later in the plot
what you're doing with these lost
functions is you're contracting
something I think I'll come to that in a
few minutes you'll see that all right so
first what I'm going to do is I'm going
to focus on a particular you right and
introduce use this loss function
definition to come up with the measure
right okay so here's my definition so
because I'm focusing a particular you I
take a joint distribution view and etc
and there's an estimator you had which
is a same support as you so the Alpha
leakage from you to X hat is defined as
follows so the adversary starts with
some prior knowledge but now I take that
probability and raise it to one minus
one over oh when I release X hat the
other so you can do better right so I'm
taking my reward function I'm going to
take its average and then find the best
estimate
and then I scared
okay alright so and
Maxwell alpha leakage then just becomes
this particular quantity I just defined
alpha linkage where I take the super-mo
overall possible use satisfying this
markov shape
okay alright so if I start with
simplifying this alpha leakage I get the
fall basically what I'm going to tell
you is that alpha leakage what I given
you so it was it could have been raised
in my compass dataset right giving some
release by say Broward County how much
can i leak about the particular race
thing is really the Animoto mutual
information of order alpha if I use that
loss function as an adversary so if I
use a loss function that was my
posterior belief raised to 1 minus 1
over alpha I get the area motor mutual
information and how this comes about I
basically do this optimization and do
this optimization and then it's not very
hard to see that for each optimization
the the adversary strategy is just the
Tilted this is called a tilted belief
and what it is is really so raised to
one would have been exactly what the 0 1
loss function would have achieved what
maximally could sort of would have done
you would take the best the posterior
that you could if you had complete
statistical information here you take it
to alpha and you normalize
okay
so when you work this out this turns out
to be their remote a mutual
okay
all right I'm going to illustrate this
strategy of the adversary for you for a
sec
so this is the prior if I raise you know
independent what the independent of what
the adversary is information suppose the
adversary had no release but it had to
figure it out using this loss function
this is the PU is the prior and then I
if I took the stilted distribution right
this is what it looks like so if alpha
is 1 what the adversary effectively
comes up with is a soft position which
is the entire belief and if PU is
infinity if alpha is infinity I make one
guess for are all alphas in between I'm
sort of contracting that I'm basically
ignoring the outliers as much as
possible I wait the outliers less in the
limit of waiting the outlier is less in
the limit at alpha is equal infinity I'm
only giving all the way to the most
likely event
I'm using the same binomial distribution
and just this is a visualization yes I'm
trying to understand like tation of this
alpha parameter huh somebody does not so
used to working with
okay I don't know how to think about
this somehow like my prior if I'm
supremely confident my prior and the
timing attack timing packets of the
keyboard like you shouldn't give me any
information because I really know the
distribution of pass rates maybe but if
I I'm not so confident by prior that I
should depend heavily on its timing
timing information I've just is that how
I should be thinking about how fun I'm
waiting my priority well you know you're
waiting your prior and posterior by the
same things because this alpha appears
in the numerator and denominator right
see I would have done whether had a
release or not I would have done the
same thing so the right way to look at
it from a loss function perspective is
if I could in an ideal universe do
something like a zero one make a single
decision I would one of the reasons log
loss is used in learning applications
besides it's being convex is it's just
easier for me to do a belief until the
very end and then make a decision right
now but the problem with that belief is
that it's weighting everything including
the outliers so it sometimes gets pulled
down by the outliers what this is
telling me is maybe I can just wait the
most likely ones in the limit when I go
to off it goes it's really I'm only
picking one so it's just sort of
swooping from you know take the take a
belief over every possible outcome to
take just make one decision and this
tells me maybe you just keep contracting
that and
to skip a list of the most likely so for
every increasing alpha my list get
smaller and smaller of the most likely
so it's really a loss function way of
doing a determination on what I keep or
not keep
does that make any sense yes to be the
the Alpha primitively chose my the
analyst not the adversary
the analyst we picked the health I mean
given the Alpha of the adversaries
optimal strategies that depict that to
the thing that you had there but it's
the alphas not so much reflection of how
confident the adversary is or what it's
doing and it's kind of reflects with the
analyst appears about protecting or what
doesn't care what detective it so I
guess you could rephrase the question
then we'll find the analyst how do I
pick the health this is a great
observation so if I I'll come to it a
little bit later because depending on
whether to alpha leakage or Maxima alpha
leakage in both cases it's another hyper
parameter tuning if you look at it that
way but in one case it's more important
than the other just because in one case
there's no monotonously and the other
there is I just understand what Aaron's
come on what do you mean the mechanism
designer not their first is designing
the arrow from xx that the person who
picks that that's even yeah yeah
why as an adversary ho try all office
not sure I'm convinced by her you mean
if I pick a loss function I'm an
adversary can pick any loss function if
I could really do zero one which would
be like factoring a number I would do it
but then if you take supremum over alpha
you would end up with mathematical
leakage well it depends on what I as a
data curator decide to use as a measure
there's always that problem
that's why Aaron I think is suggesting
that the data holder is the person to
decide what all the data holder should
be aware of what kind of adversary may
glean if I used a different alpha all
I'm saying is the adversary could do its
own learning given a release it's
entirely possible I picked enough and
the adversary learned more from some
other alpha I'd I don't know I'm not
giving you the answer out yet if the
mechanism designer decides on this alpha
what will be the adversary in my mind
and I wanna be in such a mechanism
design guard should I think of the alpha
P 1 or alpha me and if I want to as you
protect outliers so maybe some people in
my data are really unusual and those
presumably according to some story or
another are the people whose privacy I
should care about the most and by if I
really want to protect like what
obviously
I mean I know that it's kind of the
question like what absalom should I
think I actually I am NOT gonna answer
this question for a little bit maybe
towards the end but even maybe then not
I don't know
because I'll I'll tell you why I don't
know the answer but maybe towards your
device I the point is that you can try
to understand how the mechanism will
change and the information leakage would
change as you vary the sulfa right as a
system designer you have something that
looks like Jesse so even though the
probability of correctly guess he might
not change a lot the belief of an
adversary like might be spread out over
a set banal it's concentrated even
though if they guess from that set like
the probability of crack I guess it
might still be roughly the same so from
the point of view of this a designer
would you ideally what you would want to
do is your designer mechanism and see
what kind of guarantees you to have as
you vary this alpha and this goes from
one end from revising your belief over
the secret information view for us and
on the other hand what is the
probability of correctly guessing and I
think the interesting thing about this
analysis is that when you start looking
at mechanisms that try to control alpha
because for a given alpha you wanted to
maybe embed your mechanism with the
claim that look we have the same
mechanism is optimal for a range of
alphas or something like that that hope
to answer in some cases yeah in some
cases yeah but you'll also start seeing
this thing you may see in R any
differential privacy which is you'll
start seeing that it concentrates very
quickly and for some alphas Beyonce four
it'll pretty much become the same yes
but I I don't think that answers the
question this is what I have
like you know parameters are tuned
everyday it's one more parameter no but
I think his question is should we look
at these lost functions on the viewpoint
of the outliers and
right so if I was just doing learning I
think outliers are actually a problem
because they cause more errors from that
viewpoint III brought up outliers from a
privacy viewpoint I want to think more
before I give you an answer let me put
it that so why don't we why not finish
it maybe it'll become a little bit
clearer okay it's not yet fully concrete
here either right so so Maxwell leakage
is by definition taking alpha leakage
for a particular u and then just taking
a separate right over all possible
random function so now I can simplify
alpha leakage and I told you how to do
that that's the arremato Kappa remote of
mutual information and then I can do the
same for maximum leakage okay there's a
little bit of math in here but it's I'm
just gonna write it out so it's
basically because of the way you take
the supremum effectively it becomes just
a supremum over all possible
distributions with the same support okay
as X and so it's the air Emoto
capacity which turns out to be the same
as the simpson capacity so those two
quantities look different but when you
actually take a supermom over the input
distribution or the X let me I'm just a
communication theorist at heart then you
get these two quantities become the same
thing that may not mean much but in the
limit this is for all for strictly
greater than 1 for alpha equals 1
because I apply the limit of alpha
before I apply the supremum I get back
mutual information and not Shannon
capacity its pre-empting your question
so alpha basically traverses this whole
path
the the proof is actually very very
similar to Aaron's very similar and it
has two parts to it one is that for any
you the supermom of the re motor is
equal to the suprem of the sips and the
skins are they worked out and the second
is not the array motor but the sips in
satisfies the data processing
inequalities in both directions which is
virtually the Simpson satisfied the data
price so I can replace this you supremum
over all you by this
all right and the ability is quite
similar to I mean I'm gonna construct au
which is sort of shattering it slightly
a little bit more general than the
shattering thing but it's very similar
the idea is that X is a deterministic
function of U so where do we go from
here yes the immersion or X for all
elephant except for element so the way I
took a limit
it's also because of how mutual
information satisfies the data pressing
inequality
so I think Aaron said this too but turns
out so there's a little nuance here
there are two you know you can look at
data processing inequality in two
directions right the as you folks in the
CS I'd know to post-processing
inequality which is where I release X is
y and then Y is released is Z and so
hopefully somebody learns less about X
from Z then about Y from Z no okay
forward I said linkage so somebody
learns less about X from Z then about
then then why does from X ok all right
and then the other one is the linkage
where you so yeah so so when you release
in this sequential fashion Z should
learn less about X than it does about Y
so the interesting thing is that
that's what I will say maximum alpha
leakage satisfies both when I take that
supermom overall use you get both
whereas if I picked a particular you to
hide like race I get post-processing but
I will not get linkage so my alpha
leakage does not give me a linkage that
sort of is important because I have to
tune over alpha there's some often
between that may be more informative
than the alpha at the ends
okay
this composition as a yes the nose you
like the fixed you case the statement of
linkage would be that if you had a you
that was kind of hidden behind both x
and y yeah yeah so bu XYZ axis of sense
so you don't consider used I guess that
were such that you that's why the over
up opportunity you can consider use that
you know since at UIC from the rapper
champ and that you X rightly I think you
XYZ former Markov chain and it's still
possible in spite of that Markov chain -
yes yes because every moto does not have
a data processing recorded anniversary I
think it follows from the fact that is
this and I think this happens for
substantive but for some how far a motor
this follows from the fact that it's not
symmetric so she's gonna write it the
other way and then you have this bound
of log of the cardinality
a Simpson happens to satisfy the data
processing inequality in both directions
even without the supreme when you put
the super' remember you keep that so
maximal are four linkage satisfied in
both directions motor doesn't so then it
follows through for us if you use alpha
linkage I mean so in a lot of in
practice if you gave me a data set and
if I had to do this and some kind of
generative model where I model the
adversary and I used a particular alpha
loss function then I'm modeling the
adversary to be that particular last
function behavior I'm sort of minimizing
a remoter virtual information but I have
to tune over this alpha to do the right
thing
okay this composition is very similar to
what which he didn't even go over it's
very simple because it's a weak
composition as viewed in differential
privacy I've a dataset I release it as
say X 1 hat and another one as X 2 hat
and suppose these two guys collect you
know collude with each other and had
both X 1 and X 2 hat then I what I can
say is that you know the the total
leakage will always be bounded by the
sum of these
okay it's not very very hard and
actually again follows from taking these
suprema and things like that
okay so here's the thing when it comes
to maximal alpha leakage when I allow
you give you a guarantee using my loss
function approach for all possible
functions you then that that quantity
turns out to be monotonic so Erin had
this bound mutual information is less
than equal to any oscillator for
capacity is less than equal to maximal
leakage it turns out now there's a whole
sweep in there from alpha equals 1 to
infinity you're monotonically
non-decreasing non-decreasing basically
should never it's just not decreasing
and and the other cute thing about it is
it's actually quasi-convex in the
mechanism that allows you to learn the
mechanism so using some techniques so
this is again similar to what Aaron
wrote with the caveat I'm assuming that
X hat so maximum leakage is lower it's a
positive quantity it's strictly
non-negative it's lower bounded by 0 and
I'll tell you when that happens and it's
upper bounded by the log of the
cardinality of this data you have X
assuming that the data you release is
either the same cardinality or less same
alphabet a bit small smaller alphabet or
the same size all right for mutual
except for F equals 1 then you get the
entropy it's really the limits work all
right so zero leakage obviously is when
you release something that's independent
why are you staring hard on it is there
some way of interpolating between those
bounds like there's no like many of you
rényi entropy there's no kind of health
and notion of entropy that you can
express as give us an upper bound in
place of just love the other side oh I
had a very long chat with Vincent about
this at some point
III to the best of our knowledge that
doesn't seem to exist at the moment
maybe these bonds are loose there's the
offered self recoup sleep maximal
leakage of order alpha from X to itself
is actually log X yeah so this is this
is true for any Alpha that one
okay
maybe we can do better and we haven't
thought hard about it I mean you would
think that maybe would be a function of
alpha and go up to okay softly you just
then has this abrupt property this is
the weakest Remax to itself as a
function of alpha is entropy for how
people won as long as sports enter every
other alpha counterproof yeah there's
probably fundamental thing in matches
yeah I think it's because of the maximum
that 50 so yeah soft leakage is the full
leakage that you can get and it's
exactly what we just said I'm gonna take
an application I don't see any social
scientists a breath still pitch this
idea I don't know all right so here's a
problem right suppose you were the
census and your job is to publish a data
set you have a data set you have to
publish it and the goal of this
publishing should be that whatever you
had as a contingency table that you got
from your original data set and what you
publish those two tables should be very
very close so I ignore all these
contingency table words that's too many
words for me I use what I've learned I
call it a type right an empirical
distribution online census data should
be close to the releases empirical
distribution I'm gonna call them both
types okay so so here's our census data
and for some reason this is what that's
an example we wanna keep private so I'm
going to release this part of the data
set what I want is for any such
instantiation the released and the
original should be very close in their
distributions empirical distribution
and you could use a favorite method to
estimate the empirical distribution I'm
just going to do a counting argument
very simple right and it doesn't really
matter my measure of leakage is maximal
alpha leakage I call this distortion or
utility as hard hard because it really
doesn't depend on the distribution you
give me any instance iation with
probability 1 what I release should be
in a ball of radius with respect to the
type so whatever you release the type of
that it's empirical distribution should
be within a ball of radius T relative to
the original okay I think this might be
useful in practice right I mean the
sensors really needs to produce datasets
for statistical value so if I move too
far away maybe that might be a problem
ok so so these are the different
instance issues that could happen from
different years of collecting census
data maybe we did it every year you have
all this so for each one of these have
to have the same guarantee so this is
not an average guarantee so mappings
really independent the distribution as a
result of this and you'll see that
immediately you see the local
differential privacy is not possible in
this area ok now what's the trade-off
problem it's going to be I've written
these x ends and y ends because I mean
it's a data set of size n and that's
what I'm using to estimate the empirical
distribution right so I'm going to map X
n to X hat n really the ends didn't
matter but I we wrote it out that way
such that for each end sensation of xn
and its corresponding mapping it's
within a bounded radius o for the types
ok here's what happens I'm gonna give
you the optimal mechanism and then I'll
tell you how to compute this mechanism
all right the the optimal mechanism is
as follows if I knew the output
distribution the upper distribution is
basically going to the output is going
to lie within a ball of radius D from
any particular census in sensation
you're given
what I release so what what happens to
it the upper is really just normalized
probabilities within that ball so in
other words for every every census you
get you have a bunch of releases that
sit close by in this space and this is
how you would map to any of them how do
i compute this out for distribution it
turns out to be the solution okay to a
convex optimization
of the following form so it's different
for alpha equals 1 and alpha like was
greater than 1/4 of a equals 1 it'll
depend on the distribution let's talk
about alpha greater than 1 for a moment
okay it's really a congress so this math
in here but what I want you to take away
is that this solution is not hard to
compute and it really does not it only
depends on the support for alpha greater
than
so I think it's easier to visualize this
with an example so let's assume the
census only has a binary you know and
length binary string that it wishes to
release right so there are possibly n
plus 1 types right in types so n plus 1
so either there's 0 ones or one ones or
two ones up to 8 once I release so and
then what these are showing you is that
for a distance of 3 that these are my
nearest neighbors all right so there
exists one release in here that
satisfies that minimizes this leakage
reviews the least about what the
original X is and all functions of it
while preserving this distance
requirement and that's this so I Club
all these into one and I Club all these
into one anything would be this in this
uh this in this
the two takeaways here are I used a you
know the measure for for leakage is
obviously agnostic to the distribution
of the data the measure for distortion
was also agnostic to the distribution of
the data it's a very harsh measure
strong measure so what happens then is
the only way to minimize both leakage
and guarantee this utility was to sort
of do the best you could by clubbing
it's really like a this is just a
packing problem in some ways
how much time do I think I have about
five minutes or ten minutes I don't
didn't talk about site information so
I'm gonna very briefly touch on it okay
here's your visual for site information
you have your data set X you're gonna
release it as X hat right obviously you
don't want this adversary to learn any
function you but now the adversary could
have some Z that's obviously related
correlated with accent arbitrarily
correlate
so what the adversary can refine now if
it had this release and has this
knowledge is some you had given
excellency
all right so here's the first thing we
can capture this scenario through this
Markov chain so for any you so then you
X see an exit form of Markov chain so
this allows for any arbitrary
relationship with a ux z but given X Z X
is independent of this I mean this I
mean the adversary could have any
information in the universe what's the
most meaningful in releasing learning
about you is really this Markov chain
that's all we are arguing
in other words of the adversary at X and
Z it's gonna help but it will not help
it at all in learning anything more
about you yes it is really inspired by a
worker in that case like it wasn't this
is the marketing that we use Network and
I still to this day wonder if that's
really the Markov chain that wind should
use or whether these should be combined
with X hat rather than oh I I had lots
of slides on that and I just didn't put
it in here but we can talk offline about
it and I will will address that question
where it's just a question of whether
does this so the average I'd be able to
choose this secret based on Z or should
they if we're just gonna use Z to guess
the secret but should the choice of the
secret itself that is trying to guess in
the maximal case depend on have to
declare one you that wants ahead of time
and then the realization see merely
helps it guess you like this that's what
goes out to basically when you do the
maximal it's any you that's related to Z
how does it matter passwords and keys
and stuff and that this shouldn't depend
on the realization of Z right
so the adversary could have anything in
the universe except you only those that
are correlated would help and and and
and if the adversary already if the you
dependent on the Z then the adversary
may already have a lot of use and it may
still be interested in this particular
you that does not entirely derive a book
from Z you know what I'm saying I mean
this is certainly the more pessimistic
of the two
this is like an opportunistic adversary
when it selects you
gasps these to the Novation busy so
that's that's certain way like you know
the pessimist more pessimist or the
tooling safer to the airport
right I mean given all this how much
more can it run
yes okay so that's better no you always
want the strongest adversary okay all
right I'm super violent clean agreement
so now I can actually generalize maybe
not by the generalize alpha leakage to
condition alpha leakage and alpha
leakage keep in mind is where I pick a
you all right now I have to take a joint
distribution over the zoo the release
and my site information this is just in
the definitional sense it doesn't mean
when I design the mechanism I mean need
to do that but I'll talk about that
anymore
right so again it's a ratio but in the
numerator now I condition or not just
the release but the information what's
the best guess I can come up with when I
maximize this particular award function
relative to was the best guess I can
come up with when I maximize without the
exam right okay
so I think this it's easy to see that
this will simplify to the re moto
conditional information measure or
conditional remote Oh infamy mutual
information know what it's called
conditional area mojo mutual information
that's not very hard to see more
interesting is what happens when you
take over all possible use you could
have learned from this dataset and then
now I take a Superman with respect to
this Markov chain
okay the only reason I put this up there
is really for off it goes one you
basically get the Shannon conditional
mutual information condition on this Z
more generally you get this form which
is really the remoter channel capacity
when you're taking a maximum or all
possible realizations of this adversary
which it could be looked at as a channel
state the address is going to pick the
best you know adversaries it randomly
over zero it could have a whole bunch of
things you pick one from it that's going
to give you the most information and and
the Supermarine side now is actually
it's only a swim over the support of X
conditionals just for the information
theorists here I don't know if this
leads to a new definition of sips in
conditional I was not clear to me it's
hard to do that but okay what what's
most interesting about this is how can
we relate the two because if you can't
relate with knowledge and without
knowledge then you're it's a little
concerning and I think maybe you've done
this too it's sort of generalizes your
result for all alphas and it basically
says this under the following assumption
this assumption this Markov chain is
very important whatever I release right
conditioned on what data I have what the
adversary has is independent of what I
release in other words I assume private
randomness for the release
and really the only useful thing
adversary should have is about you know
something correlate with the X itself so
under this Markov chain you can show
that the conditional maximum alpha
linkage is always bounded by the
uncondition okay because this Markov
chain act just simplifies the
expressions on the previous so what this
means is that if I didn't know did not
know what your adversary has I could
still minimize this leakage measure and
and we'll be okay so the adversary could
have any side information why this was
VX hat for generating y
happens to us thank you so what we mean
is we have private to animals
I'm mostly done here's how I'd like to
actually visualize this oh there's an
example here do you want me to do the
example it's very simple yes okay so X
is binary and so a mapping from X to Y
is like a binary X to X hat is a binary
symmetric channel with crossover
probability P and really Z the way it's
related to XS through another binary
symmetric channel that crossover
probability Q right so forth so let's
look at the max sorry this is a typo
maximal leakage I mean for alpha greater
than 1 it becomes distribution
independent it only depends on the
channel right in this case even though
this was half and for UPIKE was 1 you
exactly get the Shannon so if you had Z
if the crossbo probability is 0 which
means X is equal to Z the conditional
maximum leakage is 0 because the
adversary already has X there's no more
that is released through this private
random channel so this mechanism okay
that's a good thing all right but if X
is so in for alpha greater than 1 they
turn out to be exactly the same and for
alpha equals 1 they're the same if Q is
Q is 1/2
other words yeah that's a little bit of
a problem because you could learn more
yeah this will be less than this
otherwise
example yeah so what I want to do next
is just visualize this in some way so
you get something out of it I think you
sort of saw this so the adversarial
model and in these measures we're going
from an adversary that just gets you
know refines a belief to you know it
effectively contracts this refinement
over a smaller and smaller support until
it makes a one hard decision so if you
look at the local differential privacy I
don't know if I can make it right
comparison but it seems that the
adversary is looking at any pairwise and
making such a decision for us here you
look at the entire alphabet while you
make this I don't even know if you're
making a hard decision it's some
probabilistic though so here's how the
the relationships go home so you have
mutual information sitting right here it
actually depends on the source
distribution and then you have maximum
offer leakage which is larger than this
maximum leakage which is larger than and
local differential privacy which is
larger there's this Rennie where we sort
of have this relationship that we can
prove the rainy is also larger than
maximum alpha leakage and then then
there's this what what we haven't been
able to entirely do with great successes
relate these two quantities but
local rainy doesn't depend on the
supportive I mean the dependent support
of the output it depends on the output
but not oh no no all of these depend on
us only through on the source only weird
support that's what I'm sorry I mean in
other words you're not using any input
the distribution of the data that you
have to make a release at all in any of
these cases you only use it
I see so here I guess what you'll say
okay economics it so Q had X is Q
excited to speak silicon demonstration
that's the output distribution even
though you're doing all this because of
the supermum it
you're not assuming any distribution for
the input oh that's what all these
measures but then the infimum is over uh
sorry I am a little daft but the infimum
is over watch them the infamouse over
the output distribution
if it was over the outdoor distribution
and and that that turns out to be a
tilted distribution because of this
alpha that's what we did before
I really cannot do such a relationship
in the in a non maximal case just for
alpha because it's not really monotonic
and so that really is a hyper parameter
that the question but I will be honest
about something given these
relationships it is not a priori clear
to me that I should just use one measure
or another it is to you I mean perhaps
in a universe to put it in a learning
theory context if we could all do zero
one loss functions we would all do that
we can't so then maybe this is a good
approximation for perhaps a zero one
adversary but even more so perhaps
there's a way to relate this model to
some adversarial loss function model
that's another way of looking at it and
and maybe you could get more utility by
just limiting yourself to these classes
of adversaries in some contexts where
it's sufficient like yesterday speaker
sort of eluded those are the sort of
takeaways I would have from this talk
one thing I do want to mention is we
have been seeing this in a lot of our
work is that it's related to epsilon
Delta do you see those kinds of you're
smiling vitally brainy and probably many
other okay so the leakages know
right right but that's for its yes for
off I goes infinity but I think we're
seeing that for I think you can see it
for any other for there is a
corresponding epsilon Delta is what I'm
saying it's not very hard to see that
I'm sorry Monica if I cut off any
question you have
sorry how do you say there is a paper
that shows that maximum alpha leakage
implies epsilon Delta yeah I mean the
Ryan orphan is actually the compare is
and it shouldn't the definition is the
same as the local people yeah clave
actually there's this notion of maximal
information approximate backs of
information
that happened where are you basically
now looking at the tire sort of dataset
instead of just a single element could
local intercept privacy would be
applying this to individual here you're
arguing up about the entire leakage from
some Albert position sort of look
looking at the leakage about the entire
dataset so then in this context the
notions parallel motions very similar
ones are referred to as maximum pressure
which is just Joint Distribution and the
product of marginals and the approximate
version of it is where you basically
like an approximate differential privacy
you allow some probability of you only
look at probabilities the ratio of
officially highly or advantage of me not
probability this tells up and basically
for these notions these recent paper
which connects is maximum leakage to
specifically approximate marks
information
[Music]
and I think they're in e-version
I wanted one question probably so is
there do it to the choice of alpha
question like is is there a kind of an
application or one can point to where
there's like a relevant value of alpha
that kind of jumps up no no no so
so all and I have argued about this for
hours and hours to discuss this for
hours and hours I don't know if I think
my answer is if you cannot implement an
adversary me I don't know what kind of
adverse ooh you want to give the best
guarantees against I think that's what
you should use what you pick as a
mechanism should be designed for the
adversary you think is the most powerful
that you want to give the best
guarantees against so going back a
little bit I took a different example
where instead of taking taking a hard
distortion I did an average distortion
meaning the distribution matters for
this you know maybe something like
having disruption about what happens in
that case is that after some alpha you
start seeing the same mechanism for all
alphas going to infinity
and I talked to Kunal at ITA I observed
that I mean they used this notion of
concentrate I mean that for large alpha
is this Renee is a very good proxy for
epsilon Delta we're seeing that behavior
when we do these mechanism you starts to
get the same epsilon Delta mechanism
after some alpha and it's not surprising
because if you go back to the loss
function viewpoint a large class of area
you can look at these lost functions
that I presented alpha loss as a class
of circuit loss functions for zero one
and with with alpha equals three or four
you're probably already hardening to
zero one it's going to be very hard to
implement it already we have some papers
on that but that's that's what's
happening so in practice if you wanted
to give guarantees against a very strong
adversary like alpha equals infinity
maybe I can implement in I could
implement it for some alpha that's not
infinity I don't want just thinking
about it in a practical sense
that's a very different just practice
right
and surrounded but you know I mean once
you raise from like a summers practical
point of view once you raise something
to the power of bekhten you're right
you're right you've already you've
already you've narrowed your space down
to just one point
if you see a vacation of the tenth
moment is bounded that's kind of like
saying I mean you know so the whole
space for plane is like more than ten
yeah I I don't know I can do I mean
thank you we have a lunch break do we
can be yeah I think I have to look at